it's
so it's my pleasure to introduce the
tuning fork us to the morning with urban
data and decision thank you about 12
years ago when I was working for BP the
oil company I had the idea that the
intersection of energy and modern
biology was going to be particularly
interesting and fertile and convinced BP
to put in five hundred million dollars
some fraction of which was spent here at
Berkley in fact in this building where
the energy Biosciences Institute lived
for five years from 2008 2012 you can
read that on the Topaz posters outside
about six years ago when I was finishing
up a stint in the Department of Energy
in the government I thought that cities
and data was going to be particularly
interesting and so went to NYU to start
an enterprise called the Center for
urban science and progress which
explores that intersection when you
think about it cities seemed at the time
and I think still are a pretty powerful
venue for data science cities matter
most of the world lives in cities now
and that fraction is growing with time
the data are plentiful and diverse we
have the digitization and opening up of
government records in cities around the
world and we have proliferation of
sensors everywhere in cities and there
are things to do there are technologies
and methodologies to develop that
lettuce acquire integrate and analyze
data there's a science to understand
about cities both their behavior of a
given city over time as well as the
intercomparison
of different cities and then there are
innumerable applications for government
in the private sector and so just about
six years ago there was an announcement
there's the mayor I was standing in the
back over there because I had no idea of
what we were actually going to do and
now six years later there is a story to
tell about some of the
we've been working on and some of the
things we've accomplished so I came out
of the Department of Energy in 2011 with
sort of the way a physicist would say it
I was going to go instrument to city I
was going to try to understand about the
condition and operation of the
infrastructure I was going to understand
about the environment and I was going to
understand about the people and how they
all interacted with one another and
there is of course lots of data out
there some of the challenges are can you
get at the data we've got organic data
flows the kind of data that the city
generates just in the course of its
operations administrative records
parking permits census things of that
sort this transactional data sales
communications there's all kinds of
operational data about how the traffic
is flowing or the utilities are running
and then we've got of course social
media sensors we all carry sensors in
our pocket these days there are portal
sensors traffic sensors and then there
are novel technology some of which I
will show you are that let us get
unusual data about how the city is
operating them so when we sorted up the
center there is a research strategy that
we lay down actually pretty consciously
at the beginning we're going to focus on
the data I was not interested in say a
new way of integrating photovoltaics
into a building or new technologies for
concrete as much as they might be
important in making cities better I was
going to focus on New York City because
that's where we were were a unit within
New York University but also because the
more data you can have about it the more
variety of data you could have about a
given city the more possibilities you
have for linking data sets together and
getting a more interesting understanding
having traffic and health and pollution
say in New York City is much more
interesting than having traffic in ten
different cities around the world also
we have to work closely with city
governments and it is hard enough to
work with one city government the
thought of working with a dozen at once
is just daunting we wanted also to
establish a center that owned the data
that it would be intimately familiar
with it it would have differential
access select access if you like to
certain data sets and be able to deploy
a unique sensor systems and then to
create having grown up in a part of my
life with the National Laboratories in
the US I knew that facilities are
important ways of generating data of
nucleating researchers together and so
the research structure is a set of user
facilities which I'll describe a little
bit about each one of them a data
facility quantified community and an
urban observatory which I'll describe a
bit more in detail a set of themes
building informatics can we understand
about the building's mobility obviously
sounds energy and that a whole host of
small projects that get executed some in
collaboration with companies others in
collaboration with the government there
are a set of themes I'm not going to go
through them in detail but energy in the
built environment social services
delivery very important in a city like
New York mobility obviously event and
pattern detection are important we'll
see that the city is a recurring entity
every day looks more or less the same as
every other and so identifying norms and
anomalies in those patterns is really
important environment air quality and
then a set of projects for the agencies
fundamentally the this kind of work at
least in its applications there are only
about three or four real applications of
big data for cities one is resource
allocation can I figure out how to
efficiently allocate resources whether
it's police on patrol or trash pickups
or where do I put pre-k facilities
the second is anomaly detection can I
find we heard yesterday and some of the
network talks about detecting anomalies
well there are anomalies in city
that can be detected using the data and
then the third I think is to construct
and validate predictive models for the
city you need the data in order to be
able to do that and all of these things
for more or less in those three buckets
so let me start with some of the records
data New York City is a big talent rich
data rich entity it's got I don't know
two dozen departments and Bloomberg in
the last several years of his last
administration took the initiative to
aggregate all of the data feeds around
the city into something called data
bridge this is a now quite old picture
but you see it's got feeds from
sanitation from finance from
transportation and so on these data sets
of which there are many only about 1200
open to the public are what you would
call a dog's breakfast of data it's
really a data heap rather than a data
facility and there are various entities
some in the government some outside who
are trying to do interesting things by
correlating and analyzing these data
sets the federal data are also available
this is a map from the Census Bureau of
the Gini index across New York City it's
a measure of income inequality never
mind the details but I put it up just to
show you the granularity with which the
demographic landscape is known and is
available so one of the facilities that
were building is the data hub which is
let's go back a set of multi-level
access data sets that have been curated
to allow coordination and linkage a set
of tools that let ordinary mortals like
social science researchers get at the
data
Julie Lane who is the vision and brains
behind the data set has developed or is
developing together with some of the
folks in Chicago
a kind of recommender system for
datasets where you might look at a data
set and then get suggestions about other
data sets that you might look at very
interesting through a social science
researcher this facility is up on the
web and available I think you need to
sign up and get approval but it's there
and operating a second facility we have
built is what we call quantified
community it is a way of doing intense
instrumentation of a neighborhood of
let's say 10,000 people or a big
building to understand again
infrastructure people environment its
instantiated in lower Manhattan in a
neighborhood called Greenpoint in
Brooklyn we use a combination of records
data and in-situ sensors to try to get
at what's going on here's an example
this is one month of hits on a Wi-Fi
access network in lower Manhattan and of
course your phone if the Wi-Fi is turned
on pings or gets pinged by the access
points as you pass by and this is as I
said about 30 days July 2015 and what
separated out are the passers-by the
visitors and the folks who actually
connect and you can see several things
one is again the repeating pattern
pulses actually three peaks every
workday in the morning at lunchtime and
in the evening you can see the July 4th
holiday which showed up over here and by
looking at when you ping certain
handsets
you can determine who lives in the area
who works in the area and who was just
passing through we do a lot with
street-level
imaging there are 600 traffic cameras in
New York City the feeds are available
publicly I think once every 10 seconds
or something like that some of the
scenes have Abbey Road like scenes where
you have a zebra crossing or a crosswalk
that's visible some of our folks Greg
Dobler and collaborators developed a
neural net that really just lets you
count the number of pedestrians in a
crosswalk and it's not perfect probably
only about 60 percent efficient but
nevertheless useful to get time
dependence here is an example going
vertically is just traffic camera number
and it's a heat map of pedestrian counts
again you can see morning lunchtime and
evening and you can see differences on
the weekends compared to the weekdays
typical pulse are shown over there and
again you see anomalies when there are
holidays you can also segregate out
neighborhood character Greenwich Village
looks very different than midtown
Manhattan for example so this is an
example of a very large found or
serendipitous data set that you can use
to start to characterize what goes on in
a city use cases for this stuff what
good is it lots of things air quality
sewer overflow etc etc I'm not going to
go into many of the details the charts
are are there and you can look at them
at your leisure let me move on to sensor
based data one of the projects we
started early on was sound in New York
City or we called it noise at the time
actually I grew up in New York City I
left 50 years ago and only came back
about 6 years ago the city is wonderful
but in fact the biggest quality-of-life
issue at least for me was the noise the
dice bang the trash cans at 2:00 in the
morning every night makes it really
difficult to sleep and so I swore we
were going to get those folks we started
up we hired a couple of postdocs about
five years ago faculty member Juan del
OH
who's a music guy actually he's a music
technologist came in and the project has
since taken off there's good NSF funding
good collaboration with the city the two
post
Charlie midwives in particular designed
a box which is about $85
when fabricated by the hundreds in China
in Ex filtrates the data through local
Wi-Fi and the innovation there's several
innovations but one of them it's got a
MEMS microphone which is good to plus or
minus 2 DB which is what you need to
enforce the noise code in New York City
there's a 2 DB precision here's a
picture of one of them deployed in near
NYU or you can see the windsock that
covers the microphone the wire that does
power and data and of course you don't
think of everything and so you realize
you need pigeon spikes at some point to
keep the pigeons off we've now got 50
roughly 50 nodes deployed around
Washington Square and some in Brooklyn
as well we'll have a hundred by the
middle of the year they're taking sound
data 24/7 sound pressure level so not
the sound itself but just the DB level
and they're taking random samples of
audio snippets at 15-second lengths
random why is that well and of course
it's all real-time to limit it back why
15 second samples you are legally not
allowed to record sound in New York City
on the street unless you are present and
so having a microphone there just to
record voices this is a wiretapping law
basically it is not legal we thought
about sitting a graduate student at the
base of each microphone but that is not
very efficient so the lawyers
in the end said 15 seconds of audio is
good enough you can do that and that's
used to train up an algorithm that does
feature detection on the sound it's done
ultimately it'll be done in the box and
so no sound is ever actually recorded
it's just feature extraction so I think
if the sound is working we can do a demo
of the Algar
them let's see if that works
girl shows up and so on basically
converts the audio stream into a
photograph or two-dimensional frequency
tone clap on the frequency time clock
okay so this is done in collaboration
with the City Department of
Environmental Protection or responsible
for enforcing the noise code alright let
me turn to a different way of looking at
the city again with sensors and the
story here starts back just about seven
years ago
well no six years ago when I saw that
picture in National Geographic it's a
thermal infrared image of lower
Manhattan and so we're looking at heat
not light and there are lots of
interesting things when you study that
image the first is you can read the
thermostat of every apartment in that
building some are hot and some are cold
all right
the second is that building we have
correlative data about it
we know what building it is it's that
address it's got a data center in it and
so it's hot on the bottom and hot at the
vents on the top and cool otherwise and
you can look at those buildings and be
horrified this is a city public housing
project and the thermostats are turned
on the heats turned on and people have
the windows open to keep the apartments
cool alright so terrible and while you
buildings are the same but that's a
different story
oh so when you think about this for a
minute it's pretty interesting it's a
single sensor it's this one infrared
camera not an ordinary camera but
nevertheless a single sensor its
synoptic there are hundreds of buildings
in the scene here at once so you get
broad coverage
it's non-permissive I didn't need to get
anybody's permission to figure out what
the thermostat settings are in those
apartments I just look it's persistent
it's not like a drone or an airplane or
a Saturn
where you get one picture every couple
days if you're lucky from the satellite
or the airplane similarly is going to
fly over many times and it's got high
granularity you can see down to the
level of individual offices or building
units and so that seemed to be pretty
interesting I brought in two cusps two
astronomers who were getting tired of
doing cosmology and wanted to do
something a little more interesting and
so we have now done a variety of imaging
modalities demonstrating what it is one
can learn about the city in the visible
in the infrared hyper spectral and hyper
temporal and I will explain those last
few if you don't know what they are
about three months ago cuts moved into
new offices but in our old offices where
we were for five years this was one of
the views it's a view looking up the
east side of Manhattan north you can see
the Empire State Building in the upper
left
that's about 3.8 miles away and there
are about I don't know I think they're
about a thousand buildings in the scene
the lower part is residential and the
upper part is mixed commercial and
residential and so we've done a lot of
different things just by watching I'll
show you examples of some of them
detection of aerosol plumes urban
vegetation hyper temporal imaging to
understand the electrical grid and so on
and I'll take you through some of that
first you got to know what you're
looking at we have a 1 foot resolution
lidar scan of the city it was done about
six years ago still good enough and it
gives you the topography of the city at
one foot resolution vertically and
horizontally and it's a simple exercise
in geometry it was actually done by a
Yale undergrad to take that data set
together with the image and identify the
XYZ coordinate of
every pixel in the image then you can
drop down to the xy-plane tap into the
city records that tell you what the
building is what goes on there how big
it is what its heating system is and so
on so we know what we're looking at this
is a segmentation of that same scene
fusing together the image the lidar map
as I mentioned the city data which is
called puto which is all about the
buildings and energy benchmarks the
buildings have been coated according to
their energy use intensity the hot ones
the the red ones turn out to be
hospitals and recording studio or
broadcast studios which of course
running 24/7 so the use of our energy
and then the rest as shown also we have
outlined in black those buildings that
heat by heavy heating oil as opposed to
natural gas you'll see in a moment that
that's an important source of pollution
in New York City so this is a time-lapse
of the lights in the visible over one
night
there are about you know I think they're
about 20,000 lights visible there and
you can see the Empire State Building
just went off we go through the night
some of the residential goes on and off
they change color and then we go through
the daytime Sun comes up starts moving
across the sky clouds will drift by in a
moment and so the question is we have
hundreds of terabytes of this stuff what
can you learn by analyzing these images
so the first thing we did was to start
to look at individual lights or windows
we went through the IRB the human
subjects board at NYU and said we want
to look at Windows and they said what do
you mean you can't do that and we said
we will keep the resolution low enough
so that you can't tell what's going on
in the window we will do all the
analysis aggregated
and anonymize so we don't know what
we're looking at and oh by the way
everybody else looks and everybody is
window anyway in New York City New York
City has the highest per-capita sales of
binoculars and telescopes all right Greg
Dobler this Missouri day is about four
years ago by hand segmented out the
image into four thousand sources rights
and this is one night in one source I
have no idea which it doesn't matter
you've run a change detection or change
point detection algorithm as we heard a
little bit about yesterday and you can
see that the light sought out at seven
o'clock at night goes down a little bit
at nine o'clock it's interesting that
the transitions occur mostly on the hour
at 23:30 there's a big drop looks like
somebody went to bed and then bit of
brightness along about midnight 12:30
baby woke up insomnia who knows what
happened alright so you can categorize
all of these on/off transitions yeah yes
this is one window for one night okay we
identify what we call a big off
transition when it looks like people
went to bed and we have a big on
transition as well this is a catalog or
a graph over three weeks of big offs on
the top and big ons on the bottom and
you can see again this kind of periodic
pattern weekend's different than
weekdays and so on and sometimes because
this is just like real astronomy you get
data drops when the system wasn't
working at all when we got much better
now this was about four years ago
interestingly the lights correlate very
well with power usage we could go to Con
Ed and get the power consumption for the
buildings that are in view and it
correlates pretty well with that so this
is a way of doing if you like remote
metering of the buildings at least in
aggregate
Sweetback rhythms were interesting also
if you take 2000 residential windows and
look on a typical Monday and just plot
in order when did the lights go off when
it doesn't look like they went to bed
you get this kind of graph so that's the
natural order of the windows on a Monday
and then you go to Tuesday and plot the
same windows in the same order and you
see that the pattern gets ratty err but
if you we plot the Tuesday windows in
their natural order it looks a lot like
the Monday windows and so at the
micro-level people are kind of random
when they shot their lights out but at
the aggregate level it's pretty dawn
repeatable and we were interested to get
validation of that by looking at some
jawbone data job on the motion detector
published some data about when people go
to sleep in New York City which is the
blue line and our big offs are not bad
or they go to sleep a little bit later
in our data than the jawbone our data
off for Manhattan and your bonus for all
of New York City the suburbs sleep a
little bit earlier than the young people
in Manhattan so it's probably okay but
anyway you get a sense of this you can
start to correlate with health with
noise and and so on alright one of the
surprises was our ability to detect soot
plumes I show you about a two minute
loop during the daytime on the top of
our standard view and on the bottom I
show you the subtracted image where
we've taken out the background and you
can see this big white blob that comes
out there as it runs in the loop and
that is that it's not the same source
but this is an example of it it is the
biggest source of particulate pollution
in New York City and being able to
identify who's doing it when where is
the stuff going is really important so
we've got now an effort to really do the
image recognition right it's not so easy
to recognize
these plumes against the heterogeneous
background of the city automatically but
it's in process there's money we've
gotten to do that another way of looking
at the city is hyperspectral your camera
takes an image in three colors RGB you
can spend seventy thousand dollars and
buy a very fancy camera that takes a
picture in 800 and something colors
namely it produces a spectrum for each
pixel so you've got a data cube and by
looking at the spectrum of each source
you can type it so here for example our
laboratory spectra of different lighting
sources LEDs high pressure sodium and so
on
and so you can take this kind of broad
picture of the city and you can assign a
technology to each of the lights that
you see here's a blow-up of the
Manhattan Bridge which is over here and
you can see that the necklace lights are
LEDs and the roadway lights are high
pressure sodium why is that interesting
well you might want to know when you
look at the residential buildings whose
using efficient lighting and who isn't
if you're in the market of Trani
a thoroughly efficiency because you're a
utility or you want to sell people light
bulbs but also there's a science thing
to understand here called the rebound
effect namely if I give you a more
efficient light you might be tempted to
leave it on longer and therefore and
thereby partially negate the efficiency
savings it's called rebound Jevons
discovered it in the 1850s or so so we
have a natural way of studying rebound
you can see when people switch
technologies did they keep their lights
on more after the switch I think it's
okay we're doing okay on time hyper
temporal imaging is another one that we
have demonstrated and now have money
from RPE to explore on grid dynamics
almost all of the light sources that you
see in a city
at a hundred and twenty Hertz so that's
just twice the line frequency because
the brightness is the square of the
voltage you have an incandescent bulb
you can see it quite easily when sources
turn on and off in your apartment for
example you will see a drop in the
brightness or a glitch in the flickering
because of the load has changed as your
fridge turns on and so on and so you can
look at that 120 Hertz by putting a
shutter in front of the camera driving
it in 119 point seven five beating down
the 120 Hertz are down to a quarter
Hertz for second period and then imaging
at imaging those much more slowly
changing scenes this is a loop that in
which we did that we image at a quarter
second so four Hertz and and so 16
images per cycle if you look at that one
source this looks like real astronomy I
mean that's what it looks like or and
then you can segment out the time
dependence of that source and do the
Fourier transform periodogram and see
that it's workers at about the right
period why is that interesting because
we can not only measure the frequency
which is not so exciting
but you can measure the phase and you
can see the phase change with time as
different loads come on as different
generators come on and off and so on so
this change in phase of course the whole
city in real time is something that we
can do thermo is also real interesting
I'll show you two thermal infrared
images actually yes taken about two
minutes apart this is the West Side of
Manhattan
Empire State Building about two point
something miles away and you can look at
the difference and okay you see some
people burning hot stuff over here but
you also see that just turned out to be
really pretty interesting what's going
on there so we have building ID we
identify it as
building not far from Google in
Manhattan and what's interesting about
that images you see the cooling towers
on the top so we caught one of the
cooling towers turn on that's pretty
interesting because I've now got a way
of watching the HVAC systems over many
hundreds of buildings at once operate
turn on and off and get a sense of
energy use occupancy and so on just to
demonstrate that the persistence of that
this is one building vent take it in the
infrared at about a distance of 400
meters over the course of a night
this is 10:00 at night - sorry 8:00 at
night - 6:00 in the morning and the blue
is a set of pixels off the building vent
the red is a set of pixels on the
building vent and you can see the
heating system of the building turning
on and off and again the ability to do
this for hundreds of buildings at once
do pattern identification outliers and
so on we think is pretty interesting all
right I think this is the last imaging
one we can do hyperspectral in the
infrared so this is from 7 to 13 microns
not visible which is like a half a
micron 7 to 13 long wave infrared 128
colors over that spectral band and each
simple molecule has a different spectral
pattern and so you can see chemicals
getting emitted from the city in real
time broad coverage this is a set of
images taken from Hoboken and you very
clearly identify freon 22 which is an
ozone eater and it's coming from old
refrigerators all right but not so
interesting perhaps this one was more
interesting
we found acetone on afternoons there it
is in the image let's see play the movie
this is about three hours or so you can
quite clearly see the acetone that this
instrument is remarkably sensitive we
sent some graduate students out with
cans of Dustoff which is some organic
molecule at about two miles and they let
the cans off and you can see them very
easily so acetone we said aha
nail salon right not really we we did
building idea course we identified at
677 Washington Street which is there in
Manhattan turns out at 679 is could to a
cleaners and they have on-site dry
cleaning and so we basically saw them
doing their business every day and can
get a sense again of how much every day
goes on alright I see adducted Lee some
time for questions one of the sensing
thing and then one of the model thing
and I think we're about done on last
Saturday the 16th of March would have
been st. Patrick's it is was st.
Patrick's Day we were supposed to have a
lighter overflight of two square miles
of Brooklyn it's unbelievably
complicated to get a plane to fly in New
York City legally but it would have
carried a very sensitive hyperspectral
imager and a very fancy lidar system to
be able to do lidar with five dimension
or five centimeter resolution which
would have got us identify curbs in the
street and so on
unfortunately the lidar instrument got
sick and they had to send it back to
Florida so we'll get to do this over
flight in another week or two but you
know that kind of high resolution
geometry of the city is of interest to
many people particularly when you
combine it with hyper spectral imaging
so that you'd get a sense of what the
material is at the same time as the
geometry and then one I think this is
the last research thing I have we
brought two cusps about two years ago
Paul Torrens who is a geographer from
Maryland and you know I used to think
geography
was the most boring subject ever when I
was in elementary school or middle
school it turns out it's really
interesting Paul as a GIS expert but
more interestingly he does modeling of
the way people interact with
infrastructure and in particular crowd
behavior so let me play this video this
is an earthquake
so there's physics in the way the
building falls and then the crowd reacts
to the earthquake these are independent
agents each agent has a mental state
perception and has body motion that's
been captured in a motion capture suite
so it meant to be as realistic as
possible about how people move in crowds
particularly in response to evacuation
situations I keep asking them how do you
know how accurate this is what are the
measures he says we're working on it but
it makes for pretty good pictures all
right let me close a couple words about
education because it's important also a
research program we have now we're now
in our fifth cohort of a one-year
master's program in urban informatics
the students come from a tremendous
variety of backgrounds everything from
data science to economics cognitive
science physics civil engineering urban
planning economics and so on they get
about 30% of their curriculum in data
science not at a very high level but
enough to be able to solve problems with
large data sets about 30% in urban how
two cities work what are the problems
and then about 40% in a capstone project
lots of students our average class is
now running about 70 and they go off and
find wonderful jobs everywhere but what
I wanted to put up was you know lots of
projects we've now will have done about
50 projects for the city by the end of
this year everything from data poverty
to understanding neighborhood dynamics
to the condition of New York City Parks
how do people use parks what's the
economic value of a park
and so on again up on the web you can
find these projects let me just close
with a couple of you know problems that
we've got as we do this and other people
do this in other cities around the u.s.
and around the world we don't have a
good way of describing cities we need an
ontology it's not well-defined data
standards are terrible data hoarding is
a big problem I like to say hoarding of
data is the second most basic human urge
the academics do it because a priority
the private sector does it because of
its commercial value and the government
departments do it because they don't
want to be embarrassed and because it's
terrific in terms of the real
applications we haven't quite figured
out yet who the customers are in this
it's not obvious how to make money doing
this which is probably important if it's
going to be sustainable citizen
acceptance privacy control who gets to
use the data I mean this chart is
probably a year or more old but it's
been brought to the fore with the face
book story in the last week or so I
think there's a big discussion to be had
about who owns the data and what can you
do with it um thank you let's start in
the back you were first yeah
so there are lots of people who try to
do this kind of thing for resilience
issues we did I mean there are many
people who do it I'll just give you one
project we did we were interested in the
economic impact of what happens if you
knock out a subway stop
so we routing of people lost time and so
on and then not only one but two subway
stops if I take out two simultaneously
how much impact is there done different
pairs and so on but there's all kinds of
things about flooding and and others so
yeah that's certainly one application of
this kind of thing absolutely we were
you know when we started we were looking
from Hoboken out to the West Side of
Manhattan
I was hoping we found a drug lab but
it's the wrong neighborhood to be
looking right so we have a grant in to
NSF I don't know what's going to get
funded so a little bit about the
instrument okay so the instrument is a
two million dollar instrument we could
not buy it but I was able to get money
to rent it for two weeks and we had a
crew come with the instrument from the
manufacturer of the owner aerospace and
so we took this data set we have a
proposal in to NSF to buy a slightly
less capable instrument for about a
million million and a half the
instrument because this infrared has to
be cooled and so it comes with a big
Dewar of liquid helium and the reason we
were looking from Hoboken rather than
our headquarters in Brooklyn because we
could not get the Dewar helium up the
stairs to the roof it just wouldn't fit
so he went to Hoboken the one we're
trying to buy has got a Peltier cooler
which is a solid-state thermo cooler and
so it basically is portable and handheld
and so on but we think there's a lot of
potential just drive around the city and
look what's that thing coming out
all right yeah it's got all kinds of
interesting legal issues too if you want
to use it you know I can't remember the
name of the court case but the cops in I
think Marin County or Sonoma were
finding somebody growing marijuana some
years ago by infrared imaging and it was
ruled the illegal search and seizure
it's not my business I just demonstrate
capabilities right the customers I'm
wondering it seems like you have a ton
of really interesting data but with
respect to what you described now you
are really just outlining the data more
than problems that could be solved using
the data is cusp also looking into like
the profit problems in cities that can
be solved using yeah sure sure yeah that
seems to be actually operational that's
like right so look there's this mobility
there's resource allocation safety and
security one of the things we did which
is not rocket science but it gives you a
sense New York City has an open data
portal or not an open data portal it
does have that but it has a portal for
services so if I need shelter food and
so on and some of the students several
years ago analyzed who was using that
portal and discovered that there were
two neighborhoods that were not using
the portal as much as they should have
been giving their demographic given
their demographics and so the city
started an advertising campaign to boost
the use of that and access to city
services so that's kind of one simple
problem some of this is not you know
fancy rocket science it's just applying
standard data science to a problem
another one we've gotten started is
smart shelters so who's using the
homeless shelters what are the return
rates and that sort of thing and how can
you make it more efficient so there are
lots of problems that we are working on
and other people are working on
all right yeah seems I wanted the
strengths is that you you have access to
a lot of different data streams most of
the use cases you showed so far so make
use of single you know like a a single
imaging facility or to help with one of
the synergies you can get between all
these differences yeah um so I'll put
back up this picture just to remind you
I'm gonna show this one so just by the
way that's the footprint of the
buildings that you see in the scene but
that one is a fusion of five different
data sets all right so I've know the
detailed building characteristics I know
the image and I have a time-dependent
video the lidar and so on
so that's a start at that but we've not
done frankly a tremendous amount about
say correlating sound together with when
the lights go on to get us and and
public health issues altogether I mean
that's all territory to be explored but
not yeah I think so I think so just so
many you know the digital exhaust the
closed-circuit TV the imaging the cell
phone tracking that is certainly
possible not only by the phone company
but by other people with some modest
technical skills
I think privacy is dead but yeah yeah I
think so I mean you know we we're an
academic organization we don't have
great resources we can already do things
that we don't I mean I should say you
know for that we don't know really we
have a chief data officer Julia Lane all
the students get trained in data ethics
data privacy all of the things we do
that touch on people go through the IRB
and we carefully log access to
restricted data sets and so on so we're
trying all right but as you all probably
know if you're inside one of the big
companies there are no such restrictions
as far as I know
five or six dead yeah Steve yeah it's
pretty amazing can get such a
high-resolution real-time and very
detailed measurements of frequency and
faints is it possible to also get
voltage measurements
there's brief the three yeah I you know
I think so get the voltage you need the
brightness but I mean you need the
brightness basically for an incandescent
bulb I don't know what happens with
fluorescents or LEDs and that's gonna be
pretty hard because of the turbulence in
the atmosphere right you see all kinds
of changes are just from the seeing the
turbulence so I don't believe so but I
don't know I mean what what you saw with
the hyper temporal the grid imaging was
taken with a pretty small lens we've
gotten money from our PE and the project
has just actually bought a bigger lens
and a video camera the postdoc shows up
in a week and we'll see just how far it
can be pushed yeah yeah the data right
now the access to the data is everything
that's why a lot of cusp is about
getting new data sources with the with
the sensors okay good thank you
[Applause]